Finding the same point in 2 views
Now that we found the coordinates of some
interesting points in both the left image
and the right image, we now need to determine
the correspondents, which interesting point
in the first image corresponds to which interesting
point in the second image. And, we have talked
before how the pixel values themselves are
not sufficiently unique.
Note the notation that I’m using here, a
leading digit, the 1 or the 2, indicates which
particular frame we are talking about. So,
this indicates the first image and this one
indicates the second image. To get around
the problem of the non-uniqueness of individual
pixel values across images, we are going to
look at W by W window of pixels centered around
each corner point.
These are group of pixels with W squared values
in it is likely to be much more unique than
a single pixel centered at the interest point.
What we’re going to do then is to compute
this window of pixels around the interest
points in the first image and around all the
interest points in the second image.
We talked previously about image similarity
measures and we are going to use them again
here to compare these windows centered on
the interest points. Let’s recap very briefly
on the utility of these features, in particular
the harris corner feature that we have just
been describing. It leads to a very concise
description of an image. Instead of an image
with millions of pixels in it, we now have
hundreds of features. The feature is a distinct
point within the scene. It’s something we
can find from one frame to the next, just
useful if that camera is moving. We only have
hundreds of these features now instead of
millions of pixels. So, the Harris algorithm
tells us the coordinates of each of these
distinct features within the image.
Now, we need to describe those features and
we do that with a W by W window of pixels
around each of those features and we use image
similarity measures to compare them across
frames. Another way of thinking about this
is we have eliminated a lot of the irrelevant
or not useful information from the image and
concentrated just on the very high value information
within the image.
This technique of finding corner features
and matching them across frames is really
useful for real time tracking as we just showed.
Of course, there are some problems with this
simple approach to feature matching. In particular,
if I have two views of the same scene but
there is a very large change in the viewpoint,
a very large change in either the position
or orientation of my camera, then the pattern
of pixels that surrounds each of these interest
points will be different. For instance, if
the pattern of pixels around a corner feature
in one image looks like this and in the case
where my second view looks more obliquely
at that particular part of the world, then
that will introduce some perspective distortion
to that particular part of the image and those
two windows will not match particularly well.
Similarly, if my camera moves a long way away
from the scene, then the image will change
in scale and the simple image matching techniques
that we used will also fail. And also, if
I rotate the camera, again the image similarity
measures will fail. So, what we need is some
way to match the region around an interest
point that is invariant to scale and to rotation.
Now, this is a huge area of research and there
is some wonderful algorithms available today
that provide this functionality. Perhaps,
one of the best known is the SIFT Detector
by David Lowe bended back in 2004. And, it
provides output something like this. Here
is the image of the building that we looked
at before and overlaid on that are a number
of what are referred to as SIFT features.
Centre of each circle represents an interest
point, a point that’s distinct enough to
find in another image.
The size of the circle sitting on top of each
of those interest points indicates something
about the scale of the feature. So, all of
the pixels that are in the circle around the
feature are used to describe that feature.
So, we can see that some features are very
small. They contain a lot of dense texture
spread over a small number of pixels. While,
some other features are very large, they encompass
the whole corner of a building. These features
also encode something about the orientation
of the feature in the image and that’s indicated
by the radial line.